hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to stop gallbladder pain
okay there's two steps one is an
acupressure technique and the other is
kind of correcting why you have the pain
in the first place now you can apply
this if you have your gallbladder out or
if you still have your gall better okay
now the instant pain relief is your
gallbladder is on the right side it's
right here it's underneath the right
ribcage hanging down like maybe an inch
or two on the right side about an inch
or two to the mitt from the midline
right about here okay so what you want
to do is you don't want to press over
the gallbladder you want to press on the
opposite side over here so you want to
press on the pancreas this organ so if
you actually put your finger over your
gallbladder and press on the opposite
side which is the mirror image side one
inch down below the ribcage two inches
to the left side you're going to press
in this one spot right through and here
you're going to find a really tender
spot on the opposite side that the
gallbladder is in and you're going to
press on that and work that out for like
a minute or two and find a little bit of
a knot and you're going to get instant
relief on your gallbladder okay so this
is a great way to eliminate the pain
from post surgery it's also to give you
some temporary relief even if you have a
gallstone
but do not press on the gallbladder if
you have pain in the gallbladder press
on the opposite mirror image side and
the way you know you get the exact spot
is it'll be very tender okay
go light and just kind of massage it
okay so that's how you get rid of the
pain now if you have a stone you're
going to have to watch my video on how
to dissolve stones you're going to need
purified bile salts I put a link down
there of what could take if you have
stone because it helps dissolve it
stones come from a lack of bile and you
need to take purify bile salts but you
know let's say you don't have stones you
just have pain or we have the
gallbladder out and it just never got
better here's some things you need to do
you need to reduce of course all this
sugar in the diet you have to get the
sugar out and the refined grains grains
breads pasta cereal crackers biscuits
waffles pancakes all these things will
really add
surveyed the gallbladder in fact that's
a started my gallbladder problem and if
you combine the grain with meat or
protein you really aggravate the
gallbladder I'll never forget in college
I made some meatloaf and I didn't know
you had to drain the grease so here I
put a whole bunch of bread whole bunch
of meat with a whole bunch of saturated
fat we'll talk about to catch up and I
ate that whole thing right before bed
big mistake wake up at two o'clock in
the morning and I am in serious pain and
of course I had no connection between
that in two weeks later because my
awareness is very low but you want to
get rid of the sugar get rid of the
grains and reduce fat especially not
certain nuts especially walnuts and
other nuts
and even peanuts will aggravate the gall
bladder okay and it's going to shoot
pain sometimes up on the right side here
or the shoulder blade on the right side
so you want to get rid of lower your
fast and also nuts and then if you eat
less frequently you will actually
decrease insulin it will give a chance
for the gall bladder to concentrate back
up because the gall bladder concentrates
bile so if you're eating too many
frequent meals then you never have
enough file so everything you just get
always this constant incomplete
digestion and because you don't have
enough file so like three meals with no
snacks would be great and even two meals
ok choline is a supplement that you can
buy at the health and store that will
help the gall bladder it helps relax the
gall bladder it helps drain things from
the liver and then kale kale and all the
cruciferous vegetables but I like kale
the best you can do a kale shake for the
link down there is really good for the
gallbladder pain because those factors
and those vegetables help dislodge and
loosen up any sludge in the gallbladder
and lastly purify bile salts I mentioned
that before that will help take the
bloating out in the pain into the link
down below thank you so much for
watching